i
[Música]
ah
la mayoría de los chilenos disfrutarán
de un día feriado este 12 de octubre en
el que se conmemora el día del encuentro
entre los dos mundos en cómo fue
bautizado en el año 2000 sin embargo una
parte importante de la población chilena
un 10% de la población mapuche saldrá un
año más a las calles en una
manifestación para mostrar su rechazo a
esta fecha emblemática en el que se
produjo o se conmemora en otros lugares
el descubrimiento de américa para ellos
las inversiones realizadas por parte de
empresas nacionales e internacionales en
sus territorios inversiones capitalistas
como forestales o mineras son una forma
de continuar el colonialismo que antes
sufrieron por parte de las naciones
europeas y de prada en sus ecosistemas y
también sus territorios el pueblo
mapuche que es conocido por haber
luchado finamente contra los españoles
pero que sucumbió a frente a los
chilenos en el siglo 19 sigue luchando
para la restitución de sus tierras
ancestrales
[Música]
día de la raza ese es el nombre que se
le da en colombia al 12 de octubre para
muchos colombianos no está claro que se
celebra ese día si una reivindicación de
la diversidad cultural y étnica en el
país o si bien para otros sectores el
día se convierte en la reivindicación
colonial de la invasión europea en los
últimos años afrodescendientes e
indígenas han puesto en duda la
celebración a no sentir que una
conquista deba ser motivo de celebración
a sus reivindicaciones además le han
sumado el derrumbe y la retirada de
esculturas de personajes coloniales de
hecho en popayán hace unas semanas unos
jóvenes indígenas misak derrumbaron la
estatua de sebastián de belalcázar con
un claro mensaje las estatuas de los
conquistadores representados como héroes
ya no deberían ser aceptables en el
siglo 21 en este contexto colectivos
indígenas tienen intención de reunirse
con el presidente colombiano iván duque
para plantearle cambios estructurales
relacionados con el exterminio de los
pueblos originarios la concentración del
poder y el fraccionamiento de la
institucionalidad
[Música]
en méxico la conmemoración de este 12 de
octubre se da en medio de una reavivada
polémica por la conquista beatriz
gutiérrez muller esposa del presidente
de lópez obrador viajó a europa para
conseguir documentos y códices relativos
a esta etapa histórica y que sean
exhibidos en el próximo año y aprovechó
su encuentro con el papá francisco para
entregarle una carta del presidente en
la que le insiste al pontífice en la
idea de que tanto la iglesia católica
como la monarquía española y el estado
mexicano ofrezcan disculpas a los
pueblos originarios por las oprobiosas
atrocidades que padecieron durante la
conquista en contraste desde chiapas el
ejército zapatista de liberación
nacional el ez ln emitió un comunicado
para asegurar justo lo contrario que ni
la iglesia ni la corona española tienen
porqué pedir perdón de nada pues los
pueblos indígenas sostienen no fueron
conquistados y a la fecha continúan en
rebeldía a la par este lunes distintas
organizaciones sociales convocan a una
movilización en defensa de la madre
tierra contra los megaproyectos del
gobierno como el tren maya y el corredor
interoceánico
[Música]